y'all both have such great style do you
know each
other I was like if that's how you
Embrace a stranger it's incredible yeah
well how's your New Year going my new
year is going I'm just I'm on the Kelly
Clarkson show come
on starting off very very well starting
off well beautiful no it's amazing
amazing New Year for me um I I feel like
I'm living into the dreams I had as a
kid now beautiful you know and so when
when when that happens in your life and
now you're in a reality it's very
strange you just trying to stay in the
moment as much as possible and take it
in take it in yeah so what do you think
like playing Dr King like what did what
did that teach you like what did you
learn from that you know strange as much
as I'm having a great year now last year
was crazy difficult loads of losses and
family losses and when I was actually um
when I was playing the character one of
my favorite speeches by him was um like
any man I'd like to live a long life
longevity has its place but I'm not
worried with that now I'm trying to do
God's Will and that really shaped my my
life at actually kind of leaning into
that you're not going to always be in
control of things you know things change
isn't it freeing though when you let go
of that you let go of it and you just
you allow life and whatever you believe
in to guide you in a new way so that was
that that's what I've kind of taken from
having the honor of playing Dr King you
know it's it's I know did you feel like
scared yeah I was like I if somebody was
just like I want you to play I'll would
be like no yeah no I'm a British boy
from North London you know you're like
oh my goodness they want me to play King
but um but you know I I got really
blessed lucky uh George Sea Wolf saw
something in me and very talented as
well kind of very kind of you and it was
like you know it was that opportunity to
uh step into what you've been trying to
cultivate your entire life you're an
actor you know we we work and we we're
waiting for that moment to really step
into something powerful uh and to play
someone that is Iconic but find a
grounded way of kind of attaching to
them you found that with a rether I'm
sure right so it's it was it was
definitely that moment for me yeah well
we're celebrating music as a movement so
music's that's got to be important in
your life right you're too passionate
you came out you're like he likes music
the thing oh what yeah yeah so what do
you like to listen to H my taste is
eclectic from like we can go like Fout
we can go you know uh gig she made a
sound an actual just gutteral soundin
gay listen I I did musicals as kid like
I played little Sammy Davis Jr and the
Json story Oliver I'm actually my next
film as a director will be directing a
musical oh my gosh that's awesome okay
all right I see
you wait that's incredible you know I
meaness
now wait is this one of the dreams thing
you've had since you were a kid that
you're now getting to step into I got an
opportunity to direct my first feature
film a year and a half ago and I'm
getting another opportunity to direct
like a much bigger feature fil film and
it's set around music it's set around
music and uh yeah so I'm I'm I'm I'm
excited like and in it is kind of
Portuguese Love by uh Tina
Marie
mean
she and I your voice would be
perfect coming I know he's
coming I know you're not offering this
and I want to introduce her singing at
the Oscars we're just putting in our
things putting in our things yes wait I
heard when you were a kid you you were
around like 11 when you worked with
Michael Jackson that's crazy so it was
1996 okay Mel's 11 years old and I'm
there like oh my gosh like here like oh
my God this is amazing and this guy
comes up and goes all right Michael
Jackson's about to come in nobody talk
to Michael don't even look at Michael
don't even and I'm like okay so all of a
sudden the doors open yeah and this guy
comes
in there's bodyguards all around him
he's in his white robe he's coming
through like this and then all of a
jumps on the stage I'm like oh my gosh
and then he leans down to me and he goes
why is everybody so quiet and he has a
deep voice Michael Jackson actually had
a deep voice I was like and he goes uh
hi my name's Michael I'm like yeah I I
know I'm aware yeah I'm aware I can't
look at you sir I can't so that was the
Brit Awards 1996 famously when um Jarvis
Cocker came on stage oh my gosh you were
there I was the little boy in the T what
happened yeah it was me wait what
happened no I did not know that yes I
was there I've been around for a while I
see someone tell me what happened you
can watch it on YouTube everyone gosh
I'm there I'm a little boy I've got a
turban on and I'm standing right next to
Michael Jackson Jarvis cocka jumps on
stage he's singing the Earth Song and he
shows his I don't know if we can say it
bottom is that okay to say shows his
bottom shows his ass yeah and and and
kind of mocking uh Michael Jackson then
everybody jumps on stage and running
around and kid uh the bottles flew and
people got hit in their face and it was
wild it was crazy and I I was one of the
kids that didn't get hit but I cried
like I did get hit cuz I thought I could
get a deal
[Applause]
here something could happen I like oh
I'm I'm H I'm
injured and Michael Jackson ended up
taking all those kids to a place called
Brent Cross Shopping Center for any you
know and and and got everybody
PlayStations what what I never got the
PlayStation but you
know sorry you know well we need to do a
short commercial break everybody you can
see Rustin on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home